avec kirill bonjour alors entre espoir
et inquiétude comment s'organise ce
retour d'enfants de jihadistes en france
alors qu'on sert que de nombreuses
associations dénoncent la lenteur du
processus
bonjour et bien hier mercredi la france
à rapatrier cet enfant djihadistes de
djihadiste français qui étaient retenus
dans des camps de déplacés sous contrôle
kurde en syrie dans le nord-est du pays
alors ces jeunes enfants âgés de 2 à 11
ans est particulièrement vulnérables ont
été remis à leur arrivée en france aux
autorités judiciaires et pris en charge
par les services sociaux
c'est ce qu'a annoncé le quai d'orsay
sans donner plus de précisions alors
parmi ces enfants trois d'entre eux font
partie de la même famille sont orphelins
pour les quatre autres ce sombre leur
mère qui ont accepté de se séparer d'eux
étant donné leur état de santé il est
vrai que ces enfants ont besoin de soins
spécifiques les conditions dans
lesquelles ils vivent dans les camps de
déplacés sont particulièrement pénibles
et il était jusque là détenus dans les
camps de roms et al rôle dans le
nord-est de la syrie
mais ces nouveaux rapatriements relance
des interrogations des familles de
djihadiste français qui réclament en
vain le retour en france des quelque 150
adultes et 200 enfants retenus en syrie
il y en a également quelques-uns en irak
depuis la chute de l'organisation état
islamique
le collectif des familles unies a estimé
dans un communiqué que cette opération
je cite laisse un goût amer
même si elle prouve encore une fois que
la france a la capacité de rapatrier qui
est le veut quand elle veut
au début du mois de décembre le comité
des droits de l'enfant de l'onu a jugé
que plus de 200 enfants français détenus
dans les camps de tentes du nord-est
syrien était en danger immédiat avec des
risques de dommages irréparables pour
leur vie leur intégrité physique et
mentale et leur développement alors
les autorités kurdes appelle les pays
concernés à les rapatrier ou à créer un
tribunal international pour les juger à
l'instar de paris la plupart des pays
notamment européens refusent de
rapatrier leurs ressortissants car ils
se heurtent à des opinions publiques
souvent très hostile évidemment à ce
retour considérant que les djihadistes
doivent rester dans le pays où ils sont
détenus pour y être jugés par les
autorités locales
paris qui compte un des plus forts
contingents européens de djihadistes
dans la zone est particulièrement montré
du doigt les gouvernements européens
estiment aussi que le retour des enfants
doit dépendre de l'autorisation des
parents et la mère d'une française
détenue à roche depuis deux ans avec ses
quatre enfants on a appelé mercredi à
emmanuel macron alors que les nouvelles
de sa fille souffrant d'une tumeur selon
son entourage sont particulièrement
préoccupantes
merci kirill pour ces précisions kirill
kotick off devant le quai d'orsay à
paris